we'll start with breaking news out of
Gabon senior members of the military
have appeared on television this morning
saying they are now in control of the
oil-rich Central African country they've
ordered all institutions to be dissolved
military leaders also announced the
cancellation of Saturday's election
results the Electoral commission says
that President Ali Bongo won a third
term in office he's said to have got
nearly 65 percent of the vote
[Music]
irresponsible after noting an
irresponsible unpredictable governance
which results in a continuous
deterioration of social cohesion that
risks leading the country to chaos today
the 30th of August 2023 in the name of
the gabonese people we the committee of
the transition and the restoration of
Institutions have decided to defend the
peace putting an end to the regime in
place
to this end the general elections of
August 26 2023 as well as the results
are canceled
the borders of the country are closed
until further notice
all the institutions of the Republic are
dissolved the government the Senate the
National Assembly the Constitutional
Court we call on the population for calm
and serenity and we affirm our
attachments to the respect of gabon's
commitments to the International
Community
you okay let me give you some
geographical context here because the
Republic of Gabon is situated on the
western shores of central Africa the
country has been run by one family for
more than 55 years Omar Bongo ondimba
was only the second president of Gabon
he came to power in 1967 following the
death of the president Leon Munda who
remained there until his death in 2009.
Ali Bongo and dimba succeeded his father
and was then re-elected as president in
August of 2016. he has so far served two
seven year terms and of course on
Wednesday it was announced that he had
won a third term following Saturday's
election now Gabon is the fourth largest
oil producer in sub-Saharan Africa the
country is a full member of OPEC let's
go to Nick hack who joins us now live
from Dhaka Nicholas you've covered
Western central Africa extensively
you've been speaking to people in this
morning what more can you tell us about
what's going on there
well from people that I spoke to in
certain neighborhood in liberville in
the capital there are scenes of Joys
with hundreds of people taking to the
streets chanting that Gabon is liberated
Gabon is free it's the end of a
one-party system or a family uh holding
on to power for the last 60 years so
there's a real a sense of joy in certain
neighborhoods and other neighborhoods
we're seeing the soldiers patrolling the
streets and and according to the people
that we spoke to there's uncertainty are
these troops that are loyal to to
alibongo or are these troops that have
orchestrated what appears to be a coup
what's interesting is the timing of all
of this so just minutes before this
address made by these soldiers on
National Television well the election
commission had announced the results to
gabon's population announcing that
alibongo had won these elections and
just minutes after we saw this
announcement where we saw members of the
military wearing red green and black
Berets the wind spoken speaking was
wearing a black Beret suggesting that he
was part of the Infantry Brigade but
there was also civilians showing a
united front saying that this is the end
of a regime and just hours before the
internet was shut down in uh in Gabon
following those elections and so now the
Japanese seem to be able to communicate
to each other and they're waking up to
what seems to be a new regime no news
yet of Ali Bongo himself but I can tell
you what when I spoke to some people
before ahead of the elections or during
the election day they were scared to
talk to communicate to tell us what was
actually happening and today they're
finally telling us how the this election
took place some of them told us they saw
a fraud on on a massive scale in the
capital lipo field where um where people
were exchanging their votes against uh
10 000 CFA bills or that they saw the
military taking out Ballot Box from
certain areas of the neighborhood really
trying to fiddle with these elections
there was no International observers
there to see what was going on what was
going on our team from Nairobi That was
supposed to be there to cover those
elections were not allowed in so this is
no surprise that there is such a level
of Joy given the fact that the situation
in this wealthy country this oil-rich
country has been deteriorating so while
this country is rich in oil it is poor
in terms of the the the the wealth
hasn't been trickling down to the
population there was a lot of anger
amongst people about that that their
circumstances have been going from bad
to worse in the last few years in Bongos
under bongo's presidency but we still
haven't heard from him we heard from
from Emmanuel macron yesterday there was
this announcement the speech made to all
of its ambassadors and we have to
remember that Gabbana is a former French
Colony that is key a strategic Ally to
France
both because of its geographical
location and both because it's oil rich
and that France has profited from this
oil uh in the last couple of years well
he said that he is standing for
democracy so it'll be interesting to see
how the French react to this coup that
just happened under their nose Indie
pravin there's two french military base
700 French soldiers in the capital
itself and it Belgium the north of the
country too now it'll be interesting to
see how they react to this situation for
the past decades they have been
supporting the regime in place they say
the Democracy in Gabon but this
democracy doesn't speak to everybody in
Gabon as you can see scenes of joy in
certain neighborhoods and a lot of
people wondering who's in charge of this
country this morning very interesting to
get your perspective Nicholas hack there
for us in Dhaka let's go to Ahmed Idris
now he joins us now live from nyami the
capital of Niger where of course just
last month the military there also took
over power Ahmed interesting listening
to Nicholas's hacks uh perspective there
about France and what their involvement
could be in the future because this
looks like another coup in a francophone
Africa I mean there seems to be at least
a pattern emerging
exactly what happened in Mali three
years ago such a chain reaction across
francophone West and central Africa and
now the region is fast becoming one of
the most politically unstable region in
in addition to insecurity as well as
economic decline so basically people are
wondering what's happening but again
when you talk to political analysts in
the region they will tell you about the
deprivations the economic Malay
the insecurity that's been there and the
inability of governments in power
democratically elected governments in
power to deal with these situations
corruption is also one of the major
factor and now it's it would be
interesting to see how the African Union
reacts to this we know the initial
reaction is to suspend countries member
countries that where cools have taken
place we've seen that with Mali we've
seen that with Guinea and now Niger and
it's expected very soon they will also
announce that gaboni suspended from the
African membership of the African Union
but what is interesting is we hardly
will see any effective sanctions being
applied on Gabon simply because of its
mineral resources something that we've
seen happening in Mali and burkinafasa
right now the expectation of many uh
political analysts in West Africa and
central Africa was that when there is a
cool the strangulation economic
strangulation should be applied to
enforce the rule that the military
should go back to the barracks and
restore democracy but what we continue
to say in these countries is that mining
of mineral resources and oil continue in
those countries so basically people are
watching but here in Niger people are
just waking up to the news and it will
glad in the heart of the military
authorities yeah that at least one other
African country have seen their way at
least Marlene okay Ahmed Idris deveras
in Miami the capital of Niger let's get
the perspective of a wigwe ague he's a
security analyst for afro politica which
is a security consultancy he joins us
now from Ankara firstly give us your
understanding of what is happening in
Gabon at the moment
yes I think uh would be cool in in Gabon
it came as a surprise but to some extent
not really because if we go back to 2016
for instance where there was an election
uh directed the election was seen as
fraudulent who protested and that was uh
alibongo's second election then there
was a coup in 20 equal attempt rather in
2019 and they cited the fact that the
elections were fraudulent and was not
representative of the will of the people
so we fast forward to last weekend's
election again we're seeing the same
pattern of people thinking they voted in
One Direction or they were never given
opportunity you know to vote for the
candidate the candidates that they chose
and that kind of widespread uh
dissatisfaction the electoral process I
think I have to underscore this fact
that gabon's the queen Gabon is very
different from what we are seeing in
other parts of West Africa because while
that is more about security and
governance this is specifically about
the electoral process because time and
time again we see these patterns repeat
in Gabon and the military comes in and
they make the same argument that's a
very good point that you make there so
what you're saying is there will be
support for this coup
yes already if you look at if you look
at the streets of Gabon people are say
British and people and celebrating the
cool and even if you if you listen to if
you look that statement of the of the
pushes you would see that they are very
much you know specifically talking about
you know transition and restoration of
Institutions so again that goes back to
like I said the electoral process and
they're dissolving all of the all of the
institutions like the Senate hoping that
in the transition process they would
maybe look at the Constitution and also
look at how to strengthen uh State
institutions regarding uh political
political process I guess the question
is what happens next and how United is
the military in what is taking place
right now we've been listening to our
correspondent talk about the influence
of France in Gabon the historical uh
influence the two military bases that
exist in France at the moment I mean how
do you think that's going to play into
things
yeah I mean this is just a the latest
blow to French influence on the
continent uh very recently president
macron was talking about democracy and
very interesting to know that he didn't
even know no comments yet but I'm sure
they are going to condemn this coup just
like they did condemn the the previous
attempt in 2019 at African Union also
will step into to con to condemn this
but gavon plays a very strategic role
for Forefront it has two bases bases in
the country uh government produces about
200 000 buyers of oil per day but all of
that all of that has not really
translated to economic uh progress for
the for the country however I think what
is key to water for is how aircast is
going to respond because while we have
been seeing cools in West Africa and
ecos has been in the spotlight this is
now the first was seen in central Africa
and how they're going to respond to this
if they are going to follow the same
script as ecowas and and in tackling the
issuing Gabon
we have of course seen this increasingly
anti-french sentiment in other West
African nations more notably in Niger
recently is it a similar situation in
Gabon
yes uh the the cooling Gabon is I think
it's more about the satisfaction with
the electoral process and the fact that
one family has ruled the country for
about 56 years you know before his
father he took over from his father in
2009 you know and and he has been in a
father room for 40 years so it is seen
as the Democratic process doesn't really
work and France might not really be Keen
to to complain about this this type of
dynastic kind of rule but people in the
country I think unlike in in Malia
Burkina Festival where we are seeing
Russian Flags there's no indication of
that yet so it is and the the sentiment
is not necessarily about
anti-france like we've seen in Nigeria
and Mali were more about this
determining the future of Gabon and
focusing more on this its own electoral
processes
let's talk a little bit more then about
the country as you say rich in oil it's
an OPEC member it's also a key producer
of this energy transitional material
like magnesium I mean we know the
borders have been shut I mean what are
the wider International ramifications of
what is going on there
yeah the oil markets are still not have
since stable they don't seem to be
um to respond to this shock but that is
because like I did say a Pokemon
produces about 200 000 buyers per day so
not not so much significant but not
enough to cause shock and across the oil
Market however I think it's uh it's
crucial to to watch closely how Regional
countries are a regional countries that
are going to respond because that would
determine whether or not this is going
to be a a coup that stays or a cool that
would not I will not be able to you know
to handle the pressure right and that's
something to watch out watch out for
again we need to also look at where what
is the state of President uh former
president Bongo if he is in a good
condition or if he's we've not seen
anything about that and that will be
something to watch out for also okay
really good to get your perspective ague
a security analyst for afro politica
speaking to us there from Ankara